[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله من الجزيره يقدم
لحضراتكم موجز الاخبار افاد الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمقتل مستوطن في اطلاق نار
بمنطقه الاغوار جنوب البحر الميت وقال
الجيش ان مسلحين كانوا يستقلون السياره
اطلق النيران على سياره اسرائيليه ثم
واصلوا طريقهم نحو اريحا واطلقوا النار
هناك على سياره ثانيه
هذا واعلنا الجيش الاسرائيلي تعزيز قوته
في منطقه نابلسماليه الضفه الغربيه بكتابه
عسكريه رابعه
مشاورات اجرها وزير الدفاع مع قياده الجيش
خلال جولته في موقعي عمليه حواره التي
اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين وقد حملت السلطه
الفلسطينيه حكومه نتنياهو مسؤوليه هجمات
المستوطنين في حواره
وقد دانه الخارجيه الامريكيه ما اسمته
العنف العشوائي الذي يشنه مستوطنون
اسرائيليون ضد الفلسطينيين واقل المتحدث
باسم الوزاره عين بلاده تتوقع من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ضمان المساءله الكامله
والمحاكمه القانونيه للمسؤولين عن هذه
الهجمات
مع اصرار الرئاسه التونسيه على انها تعمل
على تصحيح مسار الثوره قال محامي والدفاع
عن الوزير السابق الازهر العكرمي المعتقلي
فيما عرف بملف التامر على امن الدوله ان
قضيه تحقيق اصدر قرارا بايداع العكرميه
السجن في الاثناء قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه ان الجبهه ستنظم مظاهره
الاحد القادم للمطالبه بالافراج عن
المعتقلين السياسيين من جميع التيارات
قال زعيم يسكى الموالي لروسيا ان الظروف
في جبهه بخموت مواتيه لتطويق من سماه
العدو من جانبها قالت وكاله هريان
نوفوستين ناميليشيا تخوض معارك في مركز
المدينه وان جميع الطرق المؤديه اليها
اصبحت تحت السيطره هي الناريه للقوات
الروسيه
في غضون ذلك وصلت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
الى كييفا في زياره مفاجئه واعلنت الوزيره
تحويل الدفعه الاولى من الدعم المخصص
لاوكرانيا لعام
2022 بقيمه مليار وربع مليار دولار
نقلت وكاله رايز عن وزاره الدفاعيه
التايوانيه قولها ان الطائره عسكريه
امريكيه حلقت فوق مضيق تايوان وقالت
الوكاله وان الطائره الامريكيه وهي من
طرازيت بثمانيه اي بوسيدون عبر المضيقه من
الشمال الى الجنوب
واقل الجيش الصيني انه راقب الطائره
الامريكيه عن كثب واضفنا الامر يهدد الامن
والاستقرار في المضيق
وقال سفير الامريكي لدى الصين ان لدى
بلاده مسؤوليه الحفاظ على قوته العسكريه
في تايوان ومحيطها لضمان ردع اي هجمات
صينيه على الجزيره
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه كما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]